make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
today on our beyond omega level series
we are looking at a character that
really gets the respect he deserves
a character of few words or at least
words that any of us can really
understand
and arguably the most beloved floating
green ball in the marvel universe
dupe so dupe was created by peter
milligan
and mike allred and first appeared in
x-force number 116
in 2001. now as far as his origins are
the only thing we know is that according
to captain america
duke was created by the united states
toward the end of the cold war and that
dupe
brought about the fall of the berlin
wall but when we're first introduced to
dupe we don't really get any information
about his origin all we know
is that he is the cameraman for the new
x-force team that is being introduced
because
new marvel editor joe casada wanted to
totally revamp the title both visually
and narratively and so what happened was
that the x-force title
drastically shifted its focus to an
entirely new team of mutants that wanted
to use the x-force brand
to build their own celebrity and dupe
was the one that filmed their adventures
so they could go be broadcast to other
audiences
now duke remains a member of x-statics
for the first duration of the team's
existence becoming so popular
that plush volumes of him are sold in
the gift shops at the team's
headquarters
and when the team goes on a mission to
battle a group of terrorists that have
occupied a mansion
duke and his teammates are all killed in
action however
once wolverine becomes headmaster of the
jean grey institute for higher learning
we see that duke works at the school
with no explanation as to how
or when he was suddenly alive again
operating under the pretense of being an
adjunct professor
the reality is that wolverine recruited
dupe specifically to protect the school
from those who wish harm to the students
as wolverine knew he wouldn't be able to
offer adequate protection on his own
with so much of his time being devoted
to running the school now during this
time
at the jean grey school dupe wards off
such threats like the condemnation of
the school by the local zoning board
negative blog posts by disgruntled nuns
and with some help from howard the duck
a horde of robot barbarians from
dimension z actually i think it's triple
z dimension zzz
dimension boring but following the
conclusion of the wolverine and the
x-men series
duke would get his own mini series
titled all new duke that was written
by his co-creator peter milligan where
we learned the truth about duke's origin
which is extremely meta and fairly
confusing but i'll try to explain it in
a way that makes sense and so it turns
out that dupe comes from
marginalia which is a sort of pocket
dimension that exists in the margins of
reality we learned that dupe and his
parents are actually products of the
imagination of ingmar bergman a
prodigious swedish film director which
is also what gives dupe the inspiration
to pick up a camera and start making
documentaries now as a child
dupe endures a lot of abuse at the hands
of his mother because she blames him for
duke's father abandoning her or at least
that's what dupe had always believed to
be his
origin but this illusion is shattered by
reyes a mutant from the future that is
the son of wolverine and mystique during
the battle of the adam's storyline
that most people have tried their
hardest to forget about but eventually
duke finds out that he was actually
created by a hospital orderly doodling
him onto a sheet of paper and that his
mother and father had never separated
and in fact they were actually one in
the same
a single hermaphroditic entity that gave
birth to duke
through asexual means now initially this
causes duke to suffer a mental breakdown
but after talking with wolverine he's
able to make peace with his true origin
and i really hope that made sense guys
because we're dealing with a super weird
character here
but in terms of power dupe has displayed
a wide variety of abilities from the
fairly conventional to the utterly
absurd
dupe has impressive strength as he's
shown the ability to punch holes in
stone walls as well as advanced
durability being able to endure a great
deal of damage including swimming
through acid without suffering any
significant damage he also possesses a
regenerative healing factor and the
ability to fly beyond these normal
somewhat boring powers dupe has
abilities that make him unique
among marvel's most powerful characters
for example he's able to produce objects
seemingly on
cue from within his body which may be
due to an ability to store things
inside his body or maybe he can just
create things when he needs them but one
thing we do know
is that dupe is basically a
self-contained pocket universe so in
x-force number 123 which was a silent
issue presented as part of the nuff set
event in 2002 which is basically a
challenge
from marvel editorial to its writers and
artists to tell stories without relying
on dialogue in that issue
dupe wakes up and finds out that he has
a huge pimple on his forehead which
naturally he pops but when he does so
his ex-static teammates are sucked into
his body where they each endure horrific
situations before being rescued by duke
who's able to enter his own body
and help them escape by squeezing them
out of the hole created by his pimple
you know i really should have given
people a warning
that this wasn't really for the
squeamish i am obliged to explain this
character is the best i can
even if that means i have to be gross
anyway once his teammates are returned
to the reality we find out that only one
second has gone by
due to dupe literally stopping the hands
of the clock in the room suggesting
that dupe has the ability to control
time and reality as well during the
all-new dupe mini series we found out
that dupe is able to travel back and
forth
through reality to dupe space or
marginalia whatever you want to call it
and so how this manifests is that duke
basically drops into various points of
time when he's needed to do something to
move the narrative along such as fix a
plane so they can take off correctly if
the story dictates that the characters
need to fly on a plane
and so he basically serves this role for
the x-men popping up when he's needed to
do a variety of unseen things that seem
minor but are actually essential
for the plot to move forward now while
this isn't actually reality warping in
the most literal sense
dupe is able to affect reality by being
plugged into the knowledge of what is
needed
and when dupe was also proven to be a
potent offensive threat on one occasion
he's kidnapped by russians that use
duke's brain to produce powerful energy
blasts that keep the avengers at bay
this is when we find out from captain
america that dupe was a major factor in
the collapse of the soviet union
on another occasion duke battled thor
who is of course one of the strongest
characters in marvel comics when thor
hurls mjolnir at dupe
dupe absorbs it somehow multiplies it
with his body and then spits out all the
duplicates
back at thor it was amazing
now the fact that he was able to do that
with a weapon as powerful as milner
suggests that although we don't know
exactly how it works dupe is able to do
some crazy matter manipulation within
his body so yeah like i said
dupe is a crazy character but hopefully
he'll come away from this video with an
understanding of dupe as well as an
appreciation for how powerful he is i
love the name dupe to be honest with you
guys
i love that name i i love that like i
just i can't get tired of saying it
right like
dupe
[Laughter]
dupe i want to know who like like why
did they choose that name that's what i
want to know like why did they choose
the name
dupe i love that name right he just
looks funny like i really hope we end up
seeing dupe in the marvel cinematic
universe that would be amazing dude can
you imagine the toys like he'd be like
the woody
of like the marvel cinematic universe it
would be amazing
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign